Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Herzlich willkommen
zum philosophischen Stammtisch
aus dem alten Kraftwerk in Basel.
Schön, dass Sie dabei sind.
Es hat was,
gemeinsam an einem Tisch zu sitzen
und strittig
aktuelle Fragen zu diskutieren,
ohne dabei die Zensur zu fürchten.
Doch geht das heute überhaupt noch?
Oder läuft der innerliche Zensor
nicht immer mit, der bange fragt,
ob das, was ich sagen will,
überhaupt noch sagbar ist?
Ob nicht schon meine
nächste Äusserung mich den Kopf,
gar den Job kosten könnte?
Die Cancel Culture - viel diskutiert,
heftig umstritten, heute unser Thema.
WEF-Gründer Klaus Schwab.
Ex-CIA-Chef und US-General
David Petraeus.
Der ehemalige Novartis-Verwaltungs-
ratspräsident Daniel Vasella.
Ex-Nestlé-CEO Peter Brabeck.
Die Liste von Rednern, deren
Auftritte im deutschsprachigen Raum
verhindert oder von Ausschreitungen
begleitet wurden, wird immer länger.
In Zürich
wurde im Theaterhaus Gessnerallee
der Auftritt des AfD-Vordenkers und
Philosophen Marc Jongen vereitelt.
Diverse Veranstalter
luden den australischen Philosophen
Peter Singer aus, nach Protesten
von Behindertenverbänden -
mit der Begründung,
seine Äusserungen entsprächen nicht
dem "humanistisch-emanzipatorischen
Selbstverständnis" der Veranstaltung.
Empörte Kundschaft brachte
den Grossverteiler Migros dazu,
Schaumküsse wegen Rassismusvorwurfs
aus den Regalen zu nehmen.
Der Satiriker Andreas Thiel ist seit
seinen Äusserungen über den Koran
bei den meisten Kulturschaffenden
Persona non grata - ein Geächteter,
dem die Bühne genommen ist.
Cancel Culture - ist unsere
Meinungsäusserungsfreiheit in Gefahr?
Sehen wir einen Wiedereinzug
des vormodernen Prangers?
Oder erleben wir gerade
Demokratie in Reinform,
weil bisher ungehörte Stimmen
endlich ihre Rechte einfordern?
Oder wird die Cancel Culture
massiv übertrieben
und ist nicht mehr
als ein rhetorisches Manöver
konservativer Kräfte?
Also bloss ein Phantom?
Die Cancel Culture - ein Phantom oder
das eigentliche Drama unserer Zeit?
Das diskutieren wir jetzt
mit unseren Gästen.
Bei uns ist Franziska Schutzbach,
Soziologin und Geschlechterforscherin
an der Universität Basel.
Sie hat das Buch "Die Rhetorik
der Rechten" geschrieben.
Bei uns zu Gast ist Ijoma Mangold.
Er ist Literaturkritiker
bei "DIE ZEIT" und Philosoph.
Auch er hat ein Buch
zum Thema geschrieben:
"Der innere Stammtisch -
Ein politisches Tagebuch".
Herzlich willkommen.
Frau Schutzbach, Cancel Culture
muss im Moment für vieles herhalten.
Vieles
wird als Cancel Culture bezeichnet.
Sagen wir mal, im Kern geht es darum:
Personen,
die eine unliebsame Aussage machen,
werden massiv kritisiert, attackiert,
verlieren vielleicht sogar ihren Job.
Dann sagen Sie:
Solche Fälle mag es geben.
Von einer Cancel Culture,
einer Kultur des Cancelns,
kann dennoch nicht die Rede sein.
Richtig. Ich sehe Cancel-Fälle.
Ich behaupte auch nicht,
dass es solche Fälle nicht gibt.
Ich frage mich aber,
ob man von einer Kultur des Cancelns
sprechen kann.
Und ich frage mich,
inwiefern nicht mit verschiedenen
Ellen gemessen wird.
Welche Beispiele
werden herangezogen,
um eine solche Kultur zu beweisen?
Wenn z.B. - wie vor Kurzem -
die Gleichstellung in Basel
gekürzt oder abgeschafft werden soll
oder gegen Gender Studies
Vorstösse eingereicht werden
oder prominente Feministinnen
so viele Hassbotschaften bekommen,
dass sie sich zurückziehen,
oder migrantische Politiker
sich zurückziehen,
weil sie so viel Hass bekommen.
Dann gibt es
keine Feuilleton-Männer,
die einen ausführlichen Text
über Cancel Culture schreiben.
Mir fällt auf, dass dieser Begriff
sehr stark dann eine Rolle spielt,
wenn es um Anliegen
von Minderheiten geht.
Da zieht man viele Beispiele heran,
die beweisen sollen,
dass Minderheiten angeblich zu
gefährlichen Tätern geworden sind.
Das würde heissen, dass der Begriff
nur für ein Phänomen verwendet wird.
Nur wenn
die eine Seite attackiert wird.
Aber nicht, dass es
diese Cancel Culture nicht gibt.
Ja, das könnte man
anders diskutieren,
wenn man
den Begriff ausdehnen würde.
Aber im Moment wird der Begriff
meiner Ansicht nach
sehr oft dann benutzt,
wenn v.a. privilegierte Menschen,
die sich eigentlich immer
überall äussern können oder konnten,
ihre privilegierten Positionen
verteidigen.
Und wenn sie v.a. die Kritik
von Minderheiten abwehren.
Dann kommt, so beobachte ich es,
dieser Begriff.
Herr Mangold, Frau Schutzbach
nennt Schlüsselbegriffe.
Es geht um Privilegien
und die Frage nach Täter und Opfer.
Es geht um die Frage,
ob Einzelfälle ein Gesamtes ergeben.
Wenn es sich,
wie Frau Schutzbach andeutet,
um ein rein rhetorisches Gespenst
handeln sollte,
ist es doch ein
ziemlich lebendiges Gespenst, nicht?
Ich muss immer schmunzeln,
wenn jede Woche wieder gesagt wird:
"Cancel Culture
ist nur ein Gespenst, ein Phantom."
Es ist ein sehr lebendiges Phantom.
Um der analytischen Reinheit willen
ist es sinnvoll,
einen solchen Begriff
möglichst deskriptiv zu verwenden,
obwohl es
ein politischer Kampfbegriff ist.
An unserem Stammtisch
werden wir sowieso aus jedem Begriff
einen Kampfbegriff machen.
Das ist auch gut so.
Aber möglichst deskriptiv gefasst:
Es gibt das Phänomen auf beiden
Seiten des politischen Spektrums.
Es ist
eine anthropologische Konstante,
dass es Menschen
schwer erträglich finden,
dass andere andere Meinungen haben.
Das äussert sich oft im Wunsch, dass
der andere einfach verschwindet.
Es gibt verschiedene Formen
des Verschwindens.
Die muss man auch einzeln benennen.
Ich würde sagen,
dass so was wie körperliche
Bedrohung Andersdenkender
die Cancel Culture von rechts ist.
Die findet nicht
im diskursiven Rahmen statt,
den wir diskutieren, wenn wir
über linke Cancel Culture sprechen.
Bei linker Cancel Culture geht es
immer um eine kulturelle Hegemonie.
Es geht um sog. "Deplatforming".
Leute,
über deren Meinung man denkt,
sie sei nicht auf der Höhe
der Moral der Gegenwart,
sollen
erst gar keine Bühne bekommen.
Das ist der Kern der Vorstellung.
Dann geht es aber darüber hinaus.
Ich finde Deplatforming ein Problem,
weil es dumm macht.
Das ist das Problem.
Das Problem an der Cancel Culture
ist nicht so sehr ...
Für die Person, die nicht auftreten
kann, mag das ärgerlich sein.
Aber wir berauben uns
als Gesellschaft der Chance,
uns mit Leuten
austauschen zu müssen,
die Dinge anders sehen als wir -
eine tolle Herausforderung.
Das ist das Argument
von John Stuart Mill,
dem liberalen Philosophen des 19. Jh.
Er sagte, wir würden
zu einer stromlinienförmigen,
simpel denkenden Gesellschaft, wenn
wir andere Meinungen nicht aushalten.
Das ist nicht das Problem, das Sie
kritisieren würden, Frau Schutzbach.
Sie sagen:
Man nennt etwas Cancel Culture,
um gewisse Stimmen mundtot zu machen,
und behauptet,
die hätten wiederum mundtot gemacht.
Es ist quasi ein gegenseitiges
In-die-Schuhe-Schieben von Schuld.
Ich finde es interessant.
Ich bin der Meinung, dass
gerade in den letzten zehn Jahren
auch durch das Internet
extrem viele verschiedene Stimmen,
die Sie auch so schön hervorheben,
jetzt erst sichtbar geworden sind.
Die waren vorher oftmals nicht da.
Jetzt sind
ganz viele Stimmen von Minderheiten,
die man vor zehn Jahren
noch überhaupt nicht gehört hat,
sichtbar und hörbar geworden.
Sie sind nicht mehr
darauf angewiesen,
dass sie in sog. Leitmedien
eingeladen werden.
Sie können über Twitter,
über Blogging,
über eigene Medien, über eigene
Kanäle ihre Anliegen formulieren.
Das ist ja passiert.
Das passiert.
Sie sind da.
- Da bin ich anderer Meinung.
Jetzt wird das aber
als Cancel-Problem wahrgenommen.
Frau Schutzbach, darf ich ...
- Das ist politischer Kitsch.
Cancel Culture in ihrer reinsten
und durchschlagendsten Form
haben wir in den Elite-Universitäten
der amerikanischen Ostküste.
Cancel Culture ist v.a. ein
Eliten-Phänomen von Universitäten,
wo Sie vermutlich 50'000 $ Admission
pro Jahr bezahlen.
In diesem Campus-Milieu
wurden diese politischen
Reinheitsvorstellungen so stark.
Das kommt
aus dem akademischen Bereich.
Dass die dann immer im Namen
irgendwelcher Minderheiten sprechen,
ist schon klar.
Es ist ein Konzept.
Aber diejenigen,
die diesen Ton setzen,
sind keine Minderheiten.
Aber es kommt doch von der Strasse.
Das kommt aus Bewegungen
wie Black Lives Matter.
Aus allen möglichen Bewegungen.
Die Uni ist ja kein Raum, der von
der Gesellschaft abgetrennt ist.
Den Eindruck habe ich manchmal.
Ich verstehe im Moment gar nichts.
Es ist ein verwirrendes Phänomen.
Es geht offenbar darum,
dass eine Vielfalt gepriesen wird.
Es gibt neue Stimmen im Raum.
Die erzeugen neue Kontraste.
Andererseits schnurrt diese Vielfalt
auf eine Sandkastenlogik zusammen:
"Du bist blöd. Du bist auch blöd."
"Du hast angefangen. Nein, du."
Und das vermengt sich
mit Rechts und Links.
Und noch etwas ist unklar:
Sie, Herr Mangold, sagten,
es sei ein Eliten-Phänomen,
das sich
in elitären Kreisen selbst findet.
Oder es spielt sich,
wie Frau Schutzbach sagt,
eine soziale Vielfalt
von unten nach oben ab.
Es ist schwierig zu begreifen,
welche Dynamiken hinter
dem Phänomen Cancel Culture stehen.
Wäre es nicht der beste Ansatz,
sich zu fragen ...
In welchen Medien
findet Deplatforming statt?
Cancel Culture ist ein
digitales Mobilisierungsphänomen,
das ohne soziale Netzwerke
nicht so genannt sein sollte
und auch nicht existieren würde.
Nein. Aber es schlägt
auf die Kohlenstoffwelt durch.
Selbstverständlich
ist der Shitstorm ein Phänomen,
das erst im digitalen Raum
seine enorme Dynamik entfalten kann.
Aber wenn die Macht von Twitter
irgendwann so stark ist -
und das ist in den USA der Fall,
nicht in Deutschland -,
dass Chefredakteure
der "New York Times" einknicken
und ihre Redakteure entlassen,
gibt es keine Firewall mehr
zwischen Social Media
und dem analogen Alltag.
Und es macht einen Unterschied.
Es gab ja immer schon den Versuch,
Personen, die unpassende Meinungen
vertreten, mundtot zu machen.
Man hat Personen auf Scheiterhaufen
verbrannt, sie ins Exil geschickt,
ausgeschlossen,
für vogelfrei erklärt usw.
Aber es gibt doch
einen Unterschied zwischen dem,
was wir Cancel Culture nennen,
und dem, was damals passiert ist.
- Leute, die sagen,
Cancel Culture gebe es nicht,
sagen gleichzeitig,
es gab sie schon immer.
Das finde ich
eine unbefriedigende Position.
Zu sagen,
gecancelt wurde schon immer,
ist wie zu sagen,
Castingshows sind nichts Neues,
weil auch Paola und Kurt Felix
schon gecastet wurden.
Ja, die wurden auch
irgendwie selektiert,
aber mit anderen Dynamiken,
anderen Effekten, anderen Energien.
Die Energien, die
in der Cancel Culture frei werden,
sind mobhafte Zusammenballungen,
die im Internet
Geschwindigkeit und Macht simulieren,
um auf einzelne Personen
mit Schädigungsabsicht zuzugehen.
Aber es gibt auch sehr viel legitime
Kritik in diesen Shitstorms.
Es ist auch eine Form ...
Wenn jemand eine Position vertritt,
die z.B. sehr viele Menschen
rassistisch verletzt,
gibt es darauf eine heftige Kritik,
die auch ihre Legitimität hat.
Natürlich
gibt es Grenzüberschreitungen
von Angriffsarten und -formen,
die ich kritisiere
und die nicht gehen.
Also jemanden
sexistisch zu belästigen
oder mit dem Tod zu bedrohen -
logisch geht das nicht.
Aber wir müssen unterscheiden.
Wo reden wir
von einer illegitimen Prangerkultur?
Und wo ist es legitime Kritik,
die man auch aushalten muss - gerade
wenn man eine öffentliche Figur ist,
die starke Positionen vertritt.
Das machen ja viele.
Da müssen sie damit rechnen,
dass eine Antwort kommt,
die je nachdem auch heftig ausfällt.
Was unterscheidet harte Kritik
vom Shitstorm, der illegitim ist?
Das würde mich interessieren.
Und nochmals zu den Unis.
Ich kenne nicht alle Fälle
im Einzelnen.
Da sind sicher auch Dinge passiert,
die nicht gut sind.
Aber ...
- Mir geht's nicht um Einzelfälle.
Mir geht es um
das stromlinienförmige Zuschneiden
einer bestimmten Atmosphäre.
Die dem freien Denken
abträglich ist.
Genau diese Kultur ...
Ich halte dieses dauernde
Herbeireden einer Kultur
tatsächlich für einen
verschwörungstheoretischen Zugang.
Die ganze Zeit
werden einzelne Beispiele gesammelt.
Und dann werden
immer nur Halbwahrheiten erzählt,
um das Argument der Cancel Culture
machen zu können.
Da wird oft
mit Halbwahrheiten argumentiert.
Es werden immer nur
die Beispiele gesammelt,
die wiederum diese These bestätigen.
Es sind
verschwörungsähnliche Zugänge.
Was ist so schlimm,
wenn die Uni weniger elitär ist?
Wenn mehr Leute mitreden, was
an Unis gelehrt und geforscht wird?
Amerikanische Universitäten
sind krass elitär.
Diese gesellschaftliche Selektion
kann man sich hier nicht vorstellen.
Genau dort feiern Cancel Culture,
Identitätspolitik
und Diversity-Programmatik
fröhliche Urständ.
Jan-Werner Müller,
ein bekannter Politologe
mit einem Lehrstuhl in Princeton,
hat kürzlich
in einer Zeitung klar gesagt,
für ihn sei das Phänomen aufgeblasen.
Es gäbe es so gar nicht.
Erst recht nicht in Deutschland.
Darüber kann man streiten.
Aber ich möchte darüber reden,
was bei uns passiert.
Sehr oft werden Begriffe aus den USA
übernommen und 1:1 übertragen.
Das haben Sie herausgestrichen:
Es sind Campusphänomene in den USA,
die es bei uns so aber nicht gibt,
sagten Sie doch.
Wir sollten
über Cancel Culture hier sprechen.
Es wird ja gesagt,
sie komme hier vor.
In den USA gibt es
eine buchstäbliche Cancel Culture.
Da rollen Köpfe.
Leute verlieren ihre Jobs.
Das gibt es in Deutschland
überhaupt nicht.
Im Gegenteil:
Wenn Sie in den grossen Medien
gegen bestimmte identitätspolitische
Glaubenswahrheiten
oder ein bestimmtes
gepflegtes Vokabular verstossen,
sieht es im Zweifelsfall der Chef-
redakteur mit grossem Wohlwollen.
Weil der auch ein Problem hat:
Seine Belegschaft
denkt viel zu einheitlich.
Das ist am Ende tödlich
für Medien und Zeitungen.
Also hat man eigentlich
eine gute Position,
wenn man die Nische,
wider den Stachel zu löcken, nutzt.
Das hat in Deutschland
keine Konsequenzen.
Herr Mangold, gibt es eine Art
Mutzulage im Journalismus,
eine Marktlücke,
die die Cancel Culture schafft?
Die Mutigen voran.
Die brauchen wir auch. - Absolut.
Im linken Milieu wird gerne
von Diversity gesprochen.
Aber die tatsächliche
Meinungs-Diversity
finde ich manchmal erstaunlich
armselig, erstaunlich einseitig.
Trotzdem müssen wir auch
über andere Fälle sprechen.
Die passen jetzt nicht
ins Konzept Zeitung.
Aber Fernsehsendungen.
Denken wir an Dieter Nuhr.
Ein Kabarettist.
- Ein Fernsehkabarettist.
Bei ihm wird immer
sehr ausführlich betont,
wie schlecht seine Witze seien.
Offensichtlich ist damit gemeint:
Wenn Witze sehr schlecht sind,
darf man sie auch mal verbieten.
Die Deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft
DFG hat ein Jubiläum.
Dazu hat sie Kronzeugen
für einen Online-Auftritt gesucht.
Also Berühmtheiten,
die etwas dazu sagen sollen,
weshalb Forschung so wichtig ist.
Dann fragten sie, weil er
sehr bekannt ist, Dieter Nuhr.
Weil Dieter Nuhr aber
einige Witze über Greta Thunberg
und damit über Fridays for Future
und damit über die Frage
des Klimawandels gemacht hatte,
galt er in bestimmten Milieus
als Klimaleugner.
Er bestreitet das.
Das spielt keine Rolle.
Der Shitstorm war so gross,
dass die DFG in ihrer
erbärmlichen Rückgratlosigkeit
ihn wieder vom Netz genommen hat.
Daraufhin
war der Gegen-Shitstorm so gross,
dass die DFG in ihrer erneuten
erbärmlichen Rückgratlosigkeit
ihn wieder draufgestellt hat.
Das ist Cancel Culture
in Reinkultur.
Nein, haben wir nicht.
- Ah, warum?
Wir müssen überlegen,
wer hier genau gecancelt wurde.
Dieter Nuhr mit Sicherheit nicht.
Das Gleiche gilt für Lisa Eckhart.
Kommen Sie nicht mit dem Argument,
dass sie nachher noch bekannter sind
als vorher.
Doch. Genau mit diesem Argument.
- Das finde ich zynisch.
Fragen Sie die Leute vorher,
ob sie diese Bekanntheit wollen.
Man kann ganz klar sagen:
Die DFG hat mit Sicherheit
einen Fehler gemacht,
auf ein Shitstörmchen
so zu reagieren.
Das wurde auch hinlänglich bekannt.
Vielleicht ein paar Dutzend Leute
haben sich
über dieses Video aufgeregt.
Die DFG hatte Angst
und nahm es runter.
Das ist schlechte Kommunikation -
mittlerweile hat die DFG
einen Kommunikationsbeauftragten
für solche Fragen eingestellt.
Die Unis gehen nicht immer geschickt
mit solchen Problemen um.
Das zeigt die Nervosität
in diesem Kontext.
Woher kommt die Nervosität?
- Darüber sprechen wir gleich.
Das ist unser Thema. Dass es die
Nervosität gibt, darüber reden wir.
Auch. Wir haben aber
über Dieter Nuhr gesprochen.
Es ist falsch, zu sagen,
dass Dieter Nuhr gecancelt wurde.
Es ist nämlich gar nicht so einfach,
Berühmtheiten zu canceln.
Die haben immer ihr Publikum.
Viele finden Dieter Nuhr
jetzt erst recht cool.
Gott sei Dank!
Ich bin mit der Unterscheidung
USA und Europa nicht glücklich.
Es gibt eine globale mediale Sphäre.
Und globale Personen,
die so adressiert werden.
Ein bekannter Fall,
an dem sehr vieles sichtbar wird,
ist der Fall der
"Harry Potter"-Autorin J.K. Rowling.
Sie ist
in einen globalen Shitstorm geraten,
der meine Kinder
und Leserinnen und Leser weltweit
in eine Darstellungsform zwang, die
vielleicht doch problematisch war.
Genau. Es ist wichtig, dass wir uns
den genauen Wortlaut anschauen.
Bei diesen Fällen
kommt es auf die genauen Worte an.
Oft sprechen wir
sehr uninformiert über die Fälle.
J.K. Rowling hat letzten Sommer
in einem Tweet
auf einen Zeitungsbericht reagiert.
Im Zeitungsbericht war die Rede
von "menstruierenden Menschen".
Sie hat darauf geschrieben:
"Ich bin mir sicher, wir haben ein
Wort dafür. Kann mir jemand helfen?"
Sie meinte damit "Frau".
Daraufhin wurde Rowling kritisiert.
Sie legte mit drei Tweets nach
und schrieb,
das biologische Geschlecht
sei ein Fakt.
Und sie schrieb:
"Ich kenne und liebe Transmenschen,
aber das Konzept,
Geschlecht zu löschen,
hindert viele Menschen,
sinnvoll über ihr Leben zu sprechen."
Trotzdem verlangten viele Trans-
aktivistinnen und Transaktivisten,
sie zu canceln,
ihre Bücher nicht weiter zu verlegen,
nicht mehr zu kaufen, sie nicht mehr
auftreten zu lassen usw.
Sie verbrannten ihre Bücher
auf grossen Scheiterhaufen!
Frau Schutzbach,
ist diese Form von Kritik,
diese Form von Canceln
gerechtfertigt?
Nein. Diese Art von extremen,
dogmatischen Vorgehensweisen
halte ich natürlich nicht
für besonders konstruktiv.
Aber ich finde schon,
dass dann wiederum vergessen geht,
dass die Leute,
die so fundamentalistisch vorgehen,
nur ein Teil
solcher Aktivist/-innen sind.
Es gibt aber auch viele,
die anders vorgehen,
die eine sehr differenzierte Kritik
an den Aussagen von Rowling
formuliert haben.
Diese müssen auch
ernst genommen werden.
Man redet dann
überhaupt gar nicht mehr
über die inhaltliche Problematik
von Rowlings Aussagen.
Der ganze Fokus
wird auf die vermeintlich so mächtig
gewordenen Minderheiten gelegt.
Sie erscheinen
als totales Drohszenario,
obwohl die reale Situation
gerade von Transmenschen die ist,
dass es eine
der verletzlichsten Gruppen ist.
Sie werden oft umgebracht usw.
- Frau Schutzbach.
Von welchen Minderheiten,
in Gottes Namen, reden Sie?
Hollywoodstars machen nicht mehr
in "Harry Potter"-Verfilmungen mit.
Sie distanzieren sich von ...
Wie heisst sie? Emma Watson.
Ein Weltstar!
- Ja. Die bekommen Unterstützung.
Das sind keine Minderheiten.
Das sind doch keine
bedauernswert schwache Menschen.
Nein. Das ist ein System.
Das ist die Macht.
Man kann es verteidigen.
Aber es ist System und Macht.
Aber es geht um Minderheiten.
Es geht um ganz legitime
und wichtige Fragen.
Z.B.: Wollen wir inklusiv sprechen?
Sind wir bereit,
uns als Gesellschaft zu bemühen,
Menschen,
die wirklich in der Minderheit sind
und wirklich diskriminiert werden,
das ist ein Fakt ...
Wollen wir uns um die bemühen?
Das wird mit diesem Cancel-Culture-
Argument absolut abgewehrt.
Mit dem Cancel-Culture-Argument
wird völlig abgewehrt,
dass es eigentlich um ganz legitime
Kritik an J.K. Rowling geht,
die sich nicht bemühen will,
inklusiv zu sprechen.
Da würde ich sagen ...
- Ich muss kurz einhaken.
Die Deutung ...
Ich bin inhaltlich einverstanden.
Aber die Deutung des Phänomens
scheint mir fehlerlastig.
Sie hatten in Ihrem Ansatz gesagt,
sobald die Cancel Culture
ins Spiel gebracht werde,
werde nicht mehr darüber geredet,
wie es Transmenschen geht.
Der Fall J.K. Rowling
beweist das Gegenteil.
Da wurde eine globale Ikone
der Jugend ausgesucht,
um sie gezielt zu skandalisieren
auf einer lächerlich schmalen Basis.
Wozu?
Um Aktivisten und Aktivistinnen
in die Situation zu bringen,
über ihr Thema zu sprechen.
Genau das ist geschehen.
Meine Teenager-Töchter,
begannen plötzlich,
sich für die Transthematik
und -problematik zu interessieren.
Sie wurden dafür sensibilisiert.
Ich will sagen:
Genau das Gegenteil ist geschehen.
Dadurch, dass man J.K. Rowling
zum Mittel eines Zwecks erklärt hat -
zynisch, nicht fair -,
ist den Aktivist/-innen
in diesem Bereich gelungen,
was ihnen sonst nicht gelungen wäre:
Es wurde über das Thema gesprochen.
Dieses Phänomen
erklärt Cancel Culture auch.
Da werden Menschen
aufmerksamkeitsökonomisch
zum Mittel
eines aktivistischen Zwecks gemacht.
Und zwar
zu hohen biografischen Preisen.
Der Blickwinkel, den Sie aufwerfen,
ist überzeugend.
Ich würde aber hinzufügen:
Es ist nicht so,
dass der Zweck die Mittel heiligt.
Gerade in einer
gesellschaftspolitischen Diskussion,
wo die Frage nach Gender offen-
sichtlich so zentral geworden ist,
muss es schon auch möglich sein,
dass man die Vorstellung eines
biologischen Geschlechts verteidigt,
ohne dass man deswegen
des Scheiterhaufens würdig ist.
Sie kennen sich
mit der Thematik sicher besser aus.
Das meine ich ganz unironisch.
Selbst wenn die erdrückende Mehrheit
der Sozialwissenschaftler meint,
Geschlecht habe nichts
mit Biologie zu tun,
sondern sei
eine rein soziale Konstruktion,
glaube ich immer noch,
dass wir es in einer
pluralistisch-liberalen Gesellschaft
aushalten sollten, dass jemand
wie J.K. Rowling etwas anderes sagt.
Ich finde das keinen Skandal.
Man sollte durch einen solchen Satz
nicht
auf die böse Täterseite gelangen,
die Transpersonen ausgrenzen möchte.
Ich weiss nicht, ob das
in diesem Fall abgebildet wird.
Das Ganze hat eine Geschichte.
Man muss diese Tweets
hintereinander anschauen.
Es geht um die Idee, dass
beleidigende Aussagen gemacht wurden.
Man kann sich fragen,
wer definieren darf,
was objektive Kriterien
für Beleidigt-Sein sind.
Man kann
über all diese Dinge sprechen.
Diese Diskussionen sind auch wichtig.
Aber es scheint mir um das zu gehen,
was Wolfram angesprochen hat:
Man macht jemanden
zum Mittel des Zwecks,
um seine Agenda fortzusetzen.
Wir tun so, als wären das
irgendwelche Leute da draussen,
die das tun.
Es gibt den Ansatz
Moral Grandstanding -
in der Philosophie
im Moment heiss diskutiert.
Da ist die These:
Wir alle tun das ständig.
Das hat mit dem Internet zu tun.
Wir alle liken oder retweeten Dinge,
die nur darauf angelegt sind,
zu sagen: "Schaut mal,
wie woke und toll ich bin."
"Schaut mal,
ich habe es durchschaut."
In diesen Tweets
werden andere Leute niedergedrückt.
Das ist eine totale Unsitte.
Ich möchte gerne
über dieses Verhalten sprechen,
an dem wir alle beteiligt sind.
(Eilenberger) Diese Form
von Gratis-Aktivismus und Gratis-Mut,
sich mit einem Like
mit Gruppen zu solidarisieren,
für die man lebensweltlich wenig tut,
ist sicher ein Phänomen.
Das andere -
das kann ich als Person sagen,
die das Netz nutzt
und dort auch angegriffen wird:
Da unterscheiden sich
Links und Rechts nicht.
Die Niedertracht,
das Schmähen, das Bedürfnis,
auf jemanden, der schon am Boden
liegt, digital noch mal reinzutreten,
bewegt sich
jenseits von links und rechts.
Es ist der Kern der Cancel Culture.
Es appelliert an die niedrigsten
Instinkte unseres sozialen Daseins.
Und nicht
an die eingeforderte Differenzierung.
Man muss doch auch sehen,
dass die realen Machtverhältnisse
gerade in Zeiten von - jetzt ist er
zwar abgewählt - Donald Trump.
Die Machtverhältnisse
verschieben sich nach rechts.
Und die haben alles andere
als transfreundliche Politik vor.
Und schon gar nicht
feminismusfreundliche Politik.
Abtreibungsgesetze
werden rückgängig gemacht.
In diesen Zeiten
kann die Prangerkultur,
so sehr man sie hassen mag,
vielleicht ein Mittel sein,
um neben diesen Tendenzen
die eigenen Belange zu stärken.
#MeToo beispielsweise.
Der Pranger ist also legitim?
#MeToo brachte
eine Sexismus-Debatte in Gange.
Da war das Internet absolut wichtig.
Diese Frauen
gingen an die Öffentlichkeit.
Die Öffentlichkeit
ist nicht das beste Mittel.
Aber oft das letzte,
weil so viele politische Kämpfe,
strukturelle Versuche,
Dinge zu ändern ...
Z.B. dass Unternehmen
Stellen einrichten,
an die sich belästigte Frauen
wenden können.
Das alles hat nicht funktioniert.
Dann sind die Öffentlichkeit,
der Pranger, die Anklage
die Mittel, die noch bleiben.
Da muss man sich die realen Macht-
verhältnisse weltweit anschauen.
Ich finde, wir reden hier,
als wären etwa diese Trans-
und Genderanliegen wirklich
schon alle fast erreicht wären
und nur noch diese blöden Aktivisten
fundamentalistisch vorgehen.
Das stimmt nicht.
Es ist das Gegenteil.
Wir erleben politische Verhältnisse,
auch in der EU,
mit vielen christlich-
fundamentalistischen Bündnissen,
die systematisch daran arbeiten,
dass Anti-Gender-Poltik
gemacht wird,
dass bestimmte Errungenschaften
wieder zurückgedreht werden.
Das ist doch die Ausgangslage.
Ich teile Ihre
Wirklichkeitsbeschreibung nicht.
Ich würde sagen, wir haben es
mit unterschiedlichen
gesellschaftlichen Räumen zu tun.
Die USA unter Trump
teilen sich in die Flyover-States,
die Trump gewählt haben,
und die beiden Küsten,
die völlig anders ausgerichtet sind.
Ich gebe zu:
Wenn ich
über so ein Phänomen nachdenke,
gehe ich immer
von meiner Lebenswelt aus.
In einer so geschlossenen Blase,
in meiner einseitigen Lebenswelt,
gibt es keine Trump-Anhänger.
Über die Wirklichkeit, die ich
beruflich und privat beobachte,
würde ich sagen:
Die Machtverhältnisse
sehen eigentlich umgekehrt aus.
Ich würde im Gegenteil sagen,
und das gefällt mir gar nicht:
Wir leben
seit fünf oder sechs Jahren
in einem öffentlichen Diskurs,
bei dem derjenige
kulturell-hegemonial
die Meinungshoheit hat,
der einen hohen Opferstatus
für sich beanspruchen kann.
Sie sprechen von den Minderheiten,
als wären das
die Schwächsten der Schwachen.
Wir leben längst
in einer ganz anderen Gesellschaft.
Es gibt den Begriff
der Opfer-Olympiade.
Der klingt ein bisschen zynisch,
beschreibt aber sehr viele Prozesse
in der Öffentlichkeit sehr genau.
Je mehr sie einer kollektiven Gruppe
zugehörig sind,
die historisch gesehen
als Opfergruppe dargestellt wird,
desto stärker ist ihre Stimme,
desto glaubwürdiger.
Und wenn dann jemand
anderer Meinung ist,
der möglicherweise
weiss und alt und männlich ist -
oder gar ein Cis-Mann,
was das Allerschlimmste ist -,
heisst es: "Lasst erst
die Betroffenen zu Wort kommen."
"Wer nicht selbst betroffen ist,
kann nicht mitreden."
Das ist wieder so ein Moment
der Diskursverarmung.
Es ist immer schade,
wenn jemand nicht mitreden kann.
Aber Herr Mangold.
Zu sagen, man soll die Betroffenen
auch zu Wort kommen lassen,
scheint medial
zunächst eine gute Idee zu sein.
Das passiert
in der sozialen Selektion,
die die meisten Redaktionen haben,
eben nicht,
weil man dafür
Hintergründe haben muss,
die Menschen,
die unter diesen Prozessen leiden,
meist gar nicht erreichen.
Es ist nun ja ein mediales Phänomen.
Wir müssen über Journalisten
und ihre Angst reden.
Der implizierte Zensor -
das ist meine eigene Wahrnehmung
und der Menschen,
mit denen ich arbeite -
hat sich in den letzten fünf,
sechs Jahren verändert, verschoben.
Man wird vorsichtig. Man greift
in gewisse Prozesse nicht mehr ein.
Man fragt sich, ob man sich
ein Thema noch zumuten muss.
"Was bedeutet es,
wenn ich in diese Talkshow gehe?"
"Habe ich es die darauffolgenden Tage
mit irrationalen Unflätigkeiten
im Netz zu tun?"
Wenn ich frage:
"Frau Bleisch, gibt es Frauen ..."
Wenn sie antwortet,
fragt sie sich schon,
wie das im Netz skandalisiert wird.
Diese innere, implizite Zensur,
die einreisst,
ist das eigentlich Schädliche
an diesem Problem.
Es ist doch gut,
wenn wir mehr nachdenken.
Mehr nachdenken finde ich auch gut.
Ich setze mich
auch nicht in eine Talkshow,
wo es
um die Anatomie von Zebras geht,
weil ich mich damit
nicht auseinandergesetzt habe.
Bei gewissen Dingen würde ich sagen,
es sollen die Personen sprechen,
die eine Ahnung davon haben.
Aber,
und da hast du vollkommen recht:
Es ist schon problematisch, wenn wir
Angst vor gewissen Themen haben
und nicht mehr mitdiskutieren.
Das hat damit zu tun - deshalb
müssen wir bei uns anfangen -,
wie wir miteinander umgehen.
Da gibt es nicht Links oder Rechts,
die einen oder die anderen
skandalisieren mehr.
Es ist ein Phänomen,
das uns alle angeht.
Ich denke auch, ohne Internet
wäre es nicht so weit gekommen.
Ohne soziale Medien, wo man anonym
übereinander herfallen kann,
wo man diese ganzen Mobs
organisieren kann.
Sie stellten den Pranger als
"positiv" dar, als letztes Mittel.
Das kann ich verstehen.
Gleichzeitig finde ich
den Pranger hochproblematisch.
Er ist eine Form von Lynchjustiz.
Man liefert die Leute aus.
Es gibt kein richtiges Gericht.
Es gibt keine Möglichkeit
auf Berufung.
Es gibt kein Strafmass,
das gerecht wäre.
Es wäre auch nicht klar,
wann die Sünde gebüsst ist.
Es sage auch nicht,
es sei das Beste.
Es ist oft ein letztes Mittel.
Vieles davor hat nicht funktioniert.
Als eine Form von Notwehr?
- Könnte man so sehen.
Etwas ganz Wichtiges.
Wenn wir in dieser Angst-
und Skandalisierungsschleife sind ...
In der "Sternstunde Philosophie"
gab es einen Fall,
der interessant war, weil ein
Schnipsel und Skandalisierungslogik
in den Vordergrund trat.
In einem einstündigen Gespräch
hat der Schweizer Schriftsteller
Adolf Muschg
über die Cancel Culture gesagt,
sie sei für ihn
eine Form von Auschwitz.
Und das ist ein Fehlvergleich, eine
sprachliche Form der Gleichsetzung,
die unbedingt und ohne Einschränkung
zurückzuweisen ist.
Sie hat in der Öffentlichkeit,
insbesondere auf Twitter,
eine sehr breite Gegenseite bekommen.
Gleichzeitig handelte es sich ...
Ich will es gar nicht beschönigen.
Das war eine Fehlleistung.
Man muss das markieren
und sich dagegen wehren.
Gleichzeitig
war es ein einstündiges Gespräch.
Viele Tausend Menschen haben sich
auf diesen einen Satz gestürzt.
Nicht nur,
weil sie den Vergleich falsch fanden,
sondern weil sie die Chance sahen,
eine Biografie, eine Stimme,
die ihnen aus verschiedenen Gründen
ohnehin unliebsam schien ...
Jetzt war die Gelegenheit,
das zu tun.
Wir befinden uns in einer Situation,
in der ein Satz ...
Sie, ich, Barbara.
Mit einem Satz
können wir an den Punkt kommen,
an dem unsere Karriere
nicht nur stark geschädigt,
sondern sogar zu Ende sein könnte.
Das stimmt doch nicht. - Was tut das
mit dem öffentlichen Sprechen?
Er hätte sich doch
entschuldigen können.
Er hätte das relativieren können,
sagen können,
es sei ein Scheissvergleich,
es tue ihm leid,
es sei in der Rage
blöd formuliert gewesen.
Aber was macht er?
Er gibt danach ein ganzes Interview,
in dem er die These
nochmals ausführt und bestätigt.
Da muss man einfach sagen:
Na gut, er meint es wirklich so.
Dann ist eine Person,
die wiederholt diese Holocaust-
und Auschwitz-Vergleiche macht ...
Vielleicht ...
... müssen wir tatsächlich
mit anderen Leuten über diese
Probleme reden als mit jemandem,
der Auschwitz-Vergleiche macht.
Er hat es wiederholt.
Auch J.K. Rowling
hätte sagen können:
"Okay, vielleicht muss ich mir
die Argumente mal anhören,
das ernst nehmen
und mir mal überlegen ..."
Aber sie hat volle Pulle
und affektiv dagegengehalten.
"Ich habe recht."
Das frage ich mich.
Warum können wir uns
nicht hinstellen und sagen:
Okay, vielleicht muss ich
noch mal darüber nachdenken.
Das wird schon akzeptiert.
(Bleisch) Dass man sich entschuldigt
und relativiert?
Sich entschuldigen, noch mal
nachdenken - das wird akzeptiert.
Akzeptiert wird
das strategische Zurückkriechen,
das die PR-Beauftragten der
jeweiligen Schauspieler empfehlen.
Sie sagen: "Du äusserst dich so,
damit wir unseren Frieden haben."
Die Überzeugung ist egal.
Es ist nur ein Spiel
von Beschuldigung, Pranger, Abgesang.
Das hat mit Überzeugung
extrem wenig zu tun.
Ich möchte eine These diskutieren,
die Sie schon erwähnt haben.
Das führt dazu, dass wir eine Ver-
engung des Meinungskorridors haben.
Das wird immer wieder gesagt,
wenn es um Cancel Culture geht.
Wir alle trauen uns nicht mehr,
gewissen Dinge zu sagen.
Es gibt eine Verengung
des Meinungskorridors.
Da hätte ich gerne
ein paar Beispiele.
Ich habe nach Beispielen gesucht.
Mir sind nur andere Beispiele
in den Sinn gekommen.
Als ich ein Kind war, war klar,
dass man ass, was auf den Tisch kam.
Es gab vielleicht
einzelne Vegetarier, aber wenige.
Heute ist Essen etwas, womit man
ins Fettnäpfchen treten kann.
Essen hat viel mit Identität zu tun.
Deshalb ist aber der Meinungskorridor
doch nicht enger geworden.
Im Gegenteil: Es gibt eine Vielfalt
von Meinungen über Essen.
Für die einen ist es ein Skandal,
Fleisch zu essen.
Für die anderen ein Skandal,
vegan zu essen.
Es gibt in vielen Bereichen
sehr viel mehr Meinungen.
Genau das
führt zu Friktionen und Streit.
Ist die These einer Verengung
des Meinungskorridors richtig?
Haben wir nicht viel mehr Meinungen,
und deshalb streiten wir so sehr?
Wir sitzen am Tisch. Alle reden mit.
Das heisst eben,
dass auch Meinungen,
die als unwidersprochen galten,
plötzlich infrage gestellt sind.
Ich empfinde es ganz stark so.
Es gibt viel mehr Meinungen
als in meiner Kindheit.
Es gibt viel mehr
verschiedene mögliche Positionen
zu verschiedenen Themen.
Das führt dazu, dass gerungen wird.
Wer ist stärker und kann sich
Gehör und Legitimität verschaffen?
Ein Mittel, um die andere Meinung
abzuwehren, ist zu behaupten,
es sei Cancel Culture.
Ich möchte gerne hören,
wie Herr Mangold das sieht.
Sie haben am Anfang
von dieser Verengung gesprochen.
Wenn ich zurückschaue ...
Ich bin Jahrgang 1971.
Ich hatte Lehrer,
die waren so richtige Alt-68er.
Die pflegten ...
so einen linken Habitus.
Ich bin überhaupt kein Linker,
wie man hört.
Aber eines hat mich
an den Typen immer begeistert:
Sie hielten sich ungern
an Spielregeln.
Sie hatten ein diebisches Vergnügen,
alles anders zu machen,
als es vorgeschrieben war.
Das war für mich
unter habituellem Gesichtspunkt das,
was für mich so links war.
Stand da "Das Springen
vom Beckenrand ist verboten",
musste man als Linker
unbedingt vom Beckenrand springen.
Was heute die "woken Millenials",
über die wir im Grunde reden,
wenn wir über die Trägerschicht
von Cancel Culture sprechen,
für ein Leben führen,
ist ein ganz anderes.
Alles soll reglementiert werden.
Es herrscht eine ungeheure Angst,
dass ein falsch gewähltes Wort
zu Retraumatisierungen
bei irgendwelchen Menschen führt.
Deshalb ist es zur Vermeidung
einer Mikroaggression wichtiger,
dass wir uns
auf eine bestimmte Redeform einigen.
Das finde ich
aus zwei Gründen langweilig.
Langweilig weil Einheitlichkeit
immer intellektuell unfruchtbar ist.
Und es ist eine Überschätzung
der symbolischen Ordnung.
Es ist kein Zufall,
dass zu einem Zeitpunkt,
wo der Kapitalismus in seiner realen
Struktur übermächtig wird,
diese neue Linke nur noch über
symbolpolitische Themen verhandelt.
Das Erstaunlichste ist,
dass sie dabei nicht merkt,
dass sie dies
in unmittelbarer Allianz
mit den Konzernen
des Kapitalismus tut.
Es gibt
keine gesellschaftliche Kooperation,
die diesen Diversity-Programmen ...
Ich denke gerade an Adidas.
Adidas hat vor einem Jahr
die Personalvorständin rausgeworfen,
weil sie sagte, bei Adidas
gäbe es kein Rassismusproblem.
Man würde erst mal so denken:
Wenn sie als Personalvorständin ein
Rassismusproblem bei Adidas sieht,
d a n n sollte sie gehen.
Ich will damit sagen:
Die identitätspolitische Ausrichtung
der Diskurse
wird vom Kapitalismus übernommen und
bedient, weil es ihm nicht wehtut.
Aber Sie delegitimieren ganz
zentrale Gerechtigkeitsansprüche,
die wir im Grundgesetz
und in der Verfassung stehen haben.
Wenn es darum gehen soll,
dass mehr Menschen mitreden,
dass es Inklusion
und Gleichstellung gibt,
heisst das auch, aber nicht nur,
eine gendergerechte Sprache.
Es ist ein ganz zentraler Teil,
dass wir genderinklusiv sprechen.
Ist das so?
- Natürlich.
Ist das eine notwendige Folge dessen,
was in der Verfassung steht?
Das wäre mir neu.
- Das kann man diskutieren.
Aber die tatsächliche Herstellung
von Gleichstellung
steht in der Schweizer Verfassung
und im deutschen Grundgesetz.
Aber die gendergerechte Sprache
ist kein notwendiger Schritt.
Das muss man diskutieren.
- Okay.
Aus der Forschung wissen wir,
dass gendergerechte Sprache
tatsächlich bei Mädchen bewirkt:
Wird "Ärzt/-innen" gesagt,
haben sie auch Frauen im Kopf.
Wenn ich "Ärzte" sage,
haben sie nur Männer im Kopf.
Dann reproduziert sich ein Bild.
Nur ein Nebendiskurs.
Worum es mir aber geht:
Hier werden Gerechtigkeits-
forderungen delegitimiert
mit süffisantem Abwerten
von Snowflakes
oder
Empfindlichkeitsgenerationen ...
Sie beschreiben mich gut.
Da besteht eine Aversion,
Gerechtigkeit umzusetzen,
die natürlich bedeutet, dass Leute
Platz machen müssen für andere.
Umverteilung heisst
z.B. bei der Quote:
Wenn wir mehr Frauen
im Parlament haben,
können da weniger Männer sein.
Ja, das ist Umverteilung.
Das ist kein Canceln.
Das ist Umverteilung
und Gerechtigkeit.
Jetzt geht es um die Umsetzung.
- Das würde keiner canceln nennen.
Sie bauen einen Strohmann auf.
(Eilenberger) Canceln ist
eine Strategie in einem Kampf.
Es geht um die allgemeinen
Gerechtigskeitsforderungen,
die im Moment diskutiert werden,
u.a. gleiche Vertretung
in Parlamenten.
Moment, wir verlieren
das Phänomen aus den Augen.
Sie sagten,
das würde niemand canceln nennen.
Frau Schutzbach würde sagen, in den
wenigsten Fällen gebe es ein Canceln.
Das sei gerade die Diskussion.
Machen wir die Runde doch neu auf.
Sie haben mich ein Stück weit
überzeugt, als Sie sagten,
Dieter Nuhr sei jetzt berühmter.
Was mich am meisten nervt:
Snowflake - Sie nannten es gerade.
Diese Dünnhäutigkeit
und das Rumgejammere.
Vielleicht nehmen wir
Cancel Culture in Kauf,
weil wir kämpferisch genug sind, uns
davon nicht entmutigen zu lassen.
Umgekehrt sind wir
aber auch nicht bereit,
dieser permanenten Remoralisierung
des Diskurses zu folgen.
Vielleicht wäre das viel schöner:
Wer canceln will, soll es probieren.
Ich nehme den Shitstorm in Kauf,
lasse mich aber auch nicht
auf eine Moralisierung
meines Diskruses verpflichten,
indem ich beim falschen Wort
reumütig zu Kreuze krieche:
"Ich werde nie wieder sagen:
'Menschen, die menstruieren,
wir nennen sie Frauen.'"
Vielleicht wäre die Lösung,
mehr Robustheit zu entwickeln.
Aber ist das nicht ein Angebot,
das man annehmen kann?
Eines ist ja klar:
Dieser innere Zensor ist auch
eine innere Sensibilisierung.
Natürlich denke ich
in Programmleitungstätigkeiten
mehr darüber nach, ob wir genügend
Frauen haben, divers sind.
Ich frage in meiner Themenwahl: Ist
das zu selbstverständlich gedacht?
Dieser innere Zensor
ist also ein ambivalentes Phänomen.
Frau Schutzbach sagte auch,
es gebe einen benennbaren Fortschritt
in unseren Köpfen.
Ich komme Ihnen hier sehr entgegen.
Vielleicht muss der erst mal
mit Angst etabliert werden.
Es braucht eine Angstschleife,
um so zu denken.
Keine Sorge, die Angst ist da.
Aber die Anliegen von Gerechtigkeit,
von inklusiver Gesellschaft,
die Anliegen von Minderheiten
wurden zu allen historischen Zeiten
immer als übertrieben,
anmassend und illegitim bezeichnet.
Immer!
Und das passiert gerade wieder.
Ich möchte daran erinnern, woher die
Rhetorik der Opfer, Verweichlichung,
Empfindlichkeit,
Sentimentalität kommt.
Wir haben das alles bei Goebbels,
bei Hitler,
bei den ganzen Nazis,
wie auch Otto Weininger, gesehen.
Das sind antisemitische
Verschwörungserzählungen,
wo die Idee, die Schwachen
würden plötzlich mächtig ...
Das ist das Problem der Linke.
Sie folgen einer Reinheitsfantasie
in ihren Moralidealen,
deren Gegenseite
nicht mehr unterhalb von Goebbels
und Hitler zu verorten ist.
Ich glaube schon,
dass auf der einen Seite
die Gender Studies stehen,
Menschen, die die Bücher
von J.K. Rowling verbrennen.
Aber es muss möglich sein, zu sagen,
dass die Leute auf der anderen Seite
noch nicht Goebbels
oder Hitler sind.
Da gibt es doch
bürgerliche Liberalität.
Das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Es gibt eine historische
Kontinuität, dass eine Aversion
gegen das Schwächliche,
Verweichlichte, Feminisierte
eine sehr starke Argumentation war,
meist von rechts,
um legitime Anliegen
von Minderheiten abzuwehren.
Das können wir
historisch nachzeichnen.
Eine rhetorische Striktur.
Das gängige Twitter-Shaming
gegen gecancelte Menschen lautet:
"Die sollen sich mal nicht so haben."
Ich wäre vorsichtig, diese rheto-
rische Figur einseitig zu verorten.
Ehrlich gesagt
gerade im Kontext von Muschg:
Es ist immer schwierig, mit der
Totalkeule des Nationalsozialismus
kontemporäre Dynamiken
beschreiben zu wollen.
- Darf ich versuchen, etwas Einheit
und Friede am Tisch herzustellen?
Ich möchte
noch eine Figur einbringen,
das sog. Tocqueville-Paradox.
Ich glaube wirklich, dass wir
genau das heute wieder sehen.
Die Idee bei Tocqueville war,
dass es zu dieser Art Diskurs kommt,
wenn wir mehr Gleichheit haben.
Sobald mehr Gleichheit
hergestellt ist,
wird die verbliebene Ungleichheit
als viel stossender empfunden.
Und so beginnen diese Streitereien.
Deshalb würde ich sagen: Es ist doch
grossartig, dass wir uns so streiten.
So sagt es
der Philosoph Philipp Hübl.
Wenn ich ihn richtig wiedergebe -
ich weiss nicht mehr, wo ich da las.
In statistischen Zahlen
geht Rassismus nachweislich zurück.
Der Effekt ist,
dass umgekehrt die Empfindsamkeit
für rassistische Mikroaggressionen -
dies als technischer Begriff -
zunimmt.
So entsteht das subjektive Gefühl,
die Gesellschaft sei
so tief rassistisch wie noch nie.
(Bleisch) Und die Leute wagen eher,
an diesem Diskurs teilzunehmen.
Es diskutieren nicht
nur Feuilleton-Chefs untereinander,
was geht und was nicht,
sondern alle nehmen am Diskurs teil.
Noch mal zum Meinungskorridor.
Sie sagten, es gebe
keine Ausweitung des Korridors,
sondern vielmehr
immer noch eine Verengung.
Sie erwähnten
aber gleichzeitig die Blasenbildung.
Das ist das Drama.
Es mag eine Verengung
des Meinungskorridors geben,
aber es gibt mehr Blasen.
Das Problem ist: Wir sind
in unseren Minidiskursen sehr eng,
aber es gibt viele
parallele Diskurse.
Die schlagen einander die Köpfe ein.
Barbara, in dieser Frage, wo implizit
oder explizit gecancelt wird,
ist die Blase der Wissenschaft und
Universitäten besonders interessant.
Soziologisch und von der
Parteiidentifikation wissen wir,
dass es
eine sehr unwuchtige Blase ist.
In den USA 80 zu 20,
rechts und links.
Nein, eins zu sechzehn.
In den Sozial-
und Humanwissenschaften
kommen auf einen moderat
konservativen Professor
16 liberale.
Die Frage ist auch:
Sind das Wissenschaftsmodell,
die Forschung selbst ...
In Deutschland und der Schweiz
wurden Gruppenwie Netzwerk
Wissenschaftsfreiheit gegründet,
die sagen, es gebe eine linke,
programmatische Hegemonie,
die zu Schweigezwängen
und zu Forschungstabus führt,
gegen die man sich wehren muss,
weil es sozial
unglaublich unwuchtig ist,
was sich insbesondere
in den Geisteswissenschaften
an den Universitäten zeigt.
- Ein Beispiel,
das mich beschäftigt hat:
Die Politologin Elham Manea,
eine anerkannte Politikwissenschaft-
lerin der Uni Zürich,
setzte sich fürs Burkaverbot ein und
wurde mit Morddrohungen konfrontiert.
Da kann man sich schon fragen:
Kritik in allen Ehren -
Morddrohungen
gehen meiner Meinung nach nicht.
Sie sagte dann genau:
Die Wissenschaftsfreiheit
und Meinungsäusserungsfreiheit
an der Universität sind in Gefahr.
Wir sehen, es gibt da
sicht- und unsichtare Unwuchten.
Wir haben insofern einen Konsens
gefunden, als dass wir übereinkommen,
dass die Cancel Culture eigentlich
ein Symptom des Fortschritts ist,
ein Emanzipationssymptom.
Wir werden
für die Differenzen hellhöriger,
weil schon viel erreicht ist.
Meine letzte Frage
an Sie beide in diesem Sinne:
Sollten wir die Cancel Culture
als Übergangsphänomen sehen
und sie insofern auslaufen lassen -
sie also beobachten?
Oder sollten wir sie aktiv bekämpfen
als Gefährdung der Meinungsfreiheit?
Das ist ja das Überraschende:
Ich glaube, Cancel Culture ist over.
Das Problem der Cancel Culture,
das mich wütend machte,
war vor drei bis fünf Jahren.
Als das identitätspolitische Lager
so selbstherrlich regierte,
dass seine Verlautbarungen
nie infrage gestellt wurden.
Das hat sich
im letzten Jahr total gedreht.
Mehr will ich gar nicht.
Ich will nur, dass die Gegen-
positionen auch hinterfragt werden.
Dass man nicht
wie in der Kirche nur nickt,
weil Infragestellen Ärger bedeutet.
Der Punkt ist erreicht.
Die identitätspolitische Seite,
die Cancel-Culture-Seite -
nein, lassen wir den Begriff weg.
Die identitätspolitische Seite kennt
mittlerweile Rechtfertigungsdruck.
Das ist wichtig.
Das will ich von mir.
Das mute ich Ihnen zu und Sie mir.
Darüber bin ich glücklich.
Das Schlimme sind diese Phrasen.
Eine Zeit lang hiess es immer:
Das ist Bodyshaming,
das ist Slutshaming,
das ist Rassismus,
das ist DDR 2.0,
das ist Meinungsdiktatur.
Das waren alles nur Phrasen,
aber die Leute
trugen diese Blubberphrasen
im Brustton der grossen politisch-
moralischen Aufrichtigkeit vor
und waren sich nicht bewusst,
dass sie nur Phrasen nachreden.
Herr Mangold - überraschende These:
Cancel Culture ist over.
Frau Schutzbach, bitte eine kurze
Antwort: Fängt sie erst produktiv an?
Ja, ich denke schon, dass es
jetzt produktiv werden könnte.
Auch innerhalb
von identitätspolitischen Gruppen
sind nicht alle Menschen
einheitlich.
Es gibt ja auch sehr
differenzierte Problematisierungen
von Identitätspolitik.
Die gibt es schon seit 50 Jahren -
sie wurden aber nie gehört,
weil immer ein Schreckgespenst
einer bestimmten Identitätspolitik
heraufbeschworen wurde.
Jetzt geht es darum,
zu differenzieren
und die wichtigen Forschungen und
Stimmen, die es dazu wirklich gibt,
die super interessant sind ...
Gayatri Spivak
hat schon in den 80er-Jahren
sehr eindrücklich über die Gefahr
der Selbstveropferung geschrieben,
als marxistische Theoretikerin.
Das ist ja alles da - wir beide
müssen das nicht neu erfinden.
Es muss jetzt nur endlich
differenziert diskutiert werden.
Ich sehe
eine überraschende Einigkeit.
Wir treten in eine neue,
hoffentlich produktivere Phase
in der Erkundung der Vielstimmigkeit,
die unsere Gesellschaft ausmacht.
Sie wird immer Streit
mit sich bringen, wie heute.
Vielen Dank, Franziska Schutzbach
und Ijoma Mangold.
Vielen Dank fürs Interesse
auch Ihnen zu Hause.
Nächste Woche
spreche ich mit Richard David Precht
über den Begriff der Pflicht
und warum wir sie brauchen,
wenn es mit unserer Gesellschaft
vorangehen soll.
Ich freue mich, wenn Sie dabei sind.
Eine gute Woche.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
D. Zacheo, M. Hachen - 2021